i'm very very very  careful with my words  so the pay gap exists you accept that  but you're saying  i mean the pay gap between men and women  exists but you're saying it's not  because of gender it's because women are  too agreeable to ask for pay rises one  of the reasons okay one of the reasons  so why not get them to ask for a pay  right i've done that  many many times in my career and they  just counseled oh they do it all the  time i've had many many women  extraordinarily competent women in my  clinical consulting practice and we put  together strategies for their career  development that involve continual  pushing competing for higher wages and  often tripled their wages within a  five-year period  of course so  this lady she's so annoying  she's hiding getting on my nerves like  you celebrate that isn't that what  is that what you're talking about like  it's like lady what have you done  [Music]